or là on va commencer avec un petit
email de rim qui habite en tunisie et
qui me dit j'ai 21 ans je suis
tunisienne j'adore ton émission ça
serait bien si vous invitiez jamel
debbouze il est là
germaine bonsoir
allé all-in hardy ne garder
que chef bien physiquement tu es mais je
préfère les marronniers celle qui
t'habille en ce moment
c'est des potins tmz est américaine
d'accord que j'ai trouvés par terre dans
sur une rue américaine qui s'appelle
kissinger était dit
mister jo ouais
pourquoi les premières la veste
est mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette émission j'ai l'impression que ma
vie est là j'étais un peu des trois si
vous voulez je peux m 1,2 y y voit un
autre gars si ça vous dérange est passé
à jamel c'est que la casquette un peu de
travers non
je vais t'expliquer comme je vois que tu
es habillée comme ça depuis 1964
mais connaît pas bien l'amour et aussi
parce que dehors il se passe des trucs
incroyables
jamais sortir de ta démission mais dors
tu sais qu'on a gagné la coupe du monde
c'est le style c'est le style des states
adacore oui c'est à la mode en ce moment
jamel au cinéma on vous a vu dans l'un
des plus gros cartons de l'année
exactement 1 le fabuleux destin d'amélie
poulain exactement et on va vous voir
dans l'un des plus gros cartons de
l'année prochaine qui s'appelle mission
cléopâtre c'est le nouvel astérix
réalisé par alain chabat mais robbie
exactement
non non tu fais que des cartons même
temps mais merci quand même bon sa main
pour s'habiller fait des cartons
des blacks arrêter sinon j'ai commencé à
insulter les maires il avait bien fait
mais c'est me connais vous connaissez
pas à la mode
et des trucs incroyables qui se passe là
dans les rues comment ils s'en foutent
et de ta gueule il faut que vous font
foi les faut sortir dans les magasins
jeudi les trois magasins c'est le
surplus du cirque barnum
bagages
merci beaucoup monsieur
ça fait plaisir parce que j'avais pas
quoi et quand on dit à un moment donné
des sauvés par balladur
bon alors djamel tuba ou d'en discuter
continuer je veux juste voir tirer en
géothermie est ce qu'on aura
est ce que ça fait
c'est entre ces raids a coûté ce qu'on a
envie de faire on a vite passé que sa
voiture ait demandé à mcdo oui
ça donne envie
d'être au mc drive vient de la garde non
mais là quand on voit ces des foules
attendues ton actu n'avait aucune aucune
sensibilité artistique fashion
faux pas faire la promo de six ans nancy
ouais alors lancé une collection de
fringues non pas dans le cinq films pour
rayonner vers soul music et on a creusé
des trous de passer derrière la caméra
il a d'un coup tu étais petit je
commande déjà recoins un verre d'eau qui
suit
comment ce genre de phrase que tu peux
lancer tout le monde trouve ça normal
c'était vraiment un truc à faire et puis
avec a7 directe lançait la cassette
c'est le très très bien de djamel jamais
vu une cassette pareil des actions n'a
jamais
à
on l'a fait a dit sun is et
tu vois que c'est un vrai public de
télévision regarde
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est ça la télé moderne bienvenue à
sainte-anne
atteint
donc la première vidéo jamel en scène
quatre cent mille exemplaires
kg ça fait plaisir mais personne ne
s'attendait à un tel c'est un carton
accueil c'est bon à savoir c'est bien
c'est cool alors le très très bien de
djamel donc c'est chez canal + vidéo et
ça coûte 99 francs comme le livre de
frédéric beigbeder qui avaient
énormément de succès peut-être que ça va
vous aider en même temps peut-être que
ça valait bien aussi si jamais on sait
jamais ça peut relancer le fait pour
nous alors c'est une sélection concoctée
par le génial kader aoun oui c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire c'est lui qui fait
tout en fait non il fait pas tout
s'amuse bien enceinte où les deux ma
mère va à faire les choses qui nous
amusent et wayne des joies sont donc
quelque part c'est drôle en général il
est fort il est passé par des chinois
que j'ai pas et j'ai pas eu un projet
que j'ai pas eu de la chance d'emprunter
à savoir aux sciences po par contre il a
fait sciences po lille a fait sciences
po oui monsieur il habite toujours à
bobigny dans le 93 comme quoi c'est
possible merde
donc c'est lui mais au moment de jamel
dans les années canal man et auxerre
bonjour salut c'est cool je me présente
je m'appelle de kevin c'est steven waite
il sépare voit ça de l'adev n'importe
quoi c'est pas
des arabes je ne sais pas quoi on avait
dit sa hâte de la saison déjà quand
j'étais petit je me disais ça va bien
rasé j'ai dit oui la cgem et des savoirs
bien brian je veux dire non et comment
c'est pas toi sinon je vais le dire trot
victoire à
regarder
on est bien bonjour on connaissait six
mois en berne en ligne et vous bernard
lévy bhl pondu bhl comme ça ça va
beaucoup plus vite
on a cela qu'on parle et depuis bientôt
deux heures je dédicace mon nouveau
livre une vie un chien un doute
tu as des champions d'europe cela mais à
l'époque
ça va bien très bien très bien c'est
très bien décorée à fabien
[Applaudissements]
le mandat de m
lavez la guerre n'a pu nommer ce sens
mais c'est pas
michel comment s'appelle alors cette
magnifique machine très compliqué ça
s'appelle de la part de fer et la barre
tout fait pour lui la barre de fer qu à
la barre de fer tout la barre de fer
d'ici
[Applaudissements]
arrête-moi mec tu me saoules la
main monsieur et madame karembeu punta
fils commence à tomber s'appelle
six fois 7 à ce qu'il soit 7 42
bonjour vous me reconnaissez chez jean
paul gaultier côté horreur un as parce
que je suis a vu comme un homme c'est
pour ça que vous ne connaissez pas
qu'est-ce qui fait frétiller mais
l'oreille de la sarthe ne serait ce donc
pas des gaz une grande demoiselle qui
proviennent du bas de la colline mais
oui boudu des lombards que votre vision
est juste et acer
il est vraiment mon balai mais l'amour a
ses raisons que les limites ne
connaissent pas les vraies raisons de
son amour
tu prends jamais rien quand je m'escrime
ainsi pour tous les genres fait genre on
est intime et ouais ouais ça va ça va ça
va
et dire que j'étais très content il
ajouté
[Musique]
le moment est bond james bond je
travaille au service de la reine
elizabeth 4 je m'entends bâton et deux
pouces jamais de boules qui travaille au
service de pizza pino allez
allez
bien
ok
géant québec
mais non oui
ac non rien de tout cela j'étais là
c'est énorme ça fait plaisir c'est sur
la chaîne qui avait avant là comment
elle s'appelait la chaîne la
filiale canal ouh là là quelle mémoire
c'est à dire seulement tu es et tu
t'éclates parce que tu as ta tête un
dessin un destin incroyable maintenant
du champ taq barry white et comme on dit
chez moi elles deviennent
non c'est énormément qu'il faut comme et
de jamel ont fait un jamel temps
non c'est là s'il vous plaît j'ai besoin
d'eux
jamais l'on va parler maintenant de le
sujet un petit peu plus sérieux
[Applaudissements]
on va commencer par parler de la police
la police le dommage est centré quand
vous avez je n'avais pas compris le show
et quand j'ai vu le mec comme ça au
léman ça vous a rappelé des souvenirs
alors c'est marrant quand même jamel
parce que finalement il ya joey starr
béatrice dalle samy naceri arthur nabi
larusso arthur m6 solar faudel palmade
puff daddy
très souvent la presse se fait l'écho de
deux stars qui pète un peu les plombs
comme ça devant les flics pour à bercy
par exemple histoire et séverine
logiciel qu'est ce qui se passe vous a
laissé le 1er janvier 2000 vous serez
encore en sort les deux sièges que je
comprends bien des têtes qui vont
tourner merde
vous sortez du parking de bercy dans
votre mercedes 4 4 vous mettez dans un
convoi de gendarmes mobiles qu'est ce
qui se passe au niger il ya eu 1
peut-être un malentendu de la part de
tout le monde mais mais mais moins la
mienne en tout cas ça c'est sûr gg j'ai
malencontreusement sans l'avoir vu je
suis entend dans un combat de police
effectivement et puis déjà c'est drôle
le dernier dont vous laissiez jamais
c'est drôle mais crois moi surtout ce
que j'ai de plus cher au monde que j'ai
vraiment je suis rentré je suis entré
dans cette voie et est quoi cette m plus
tard je ne suis pas arrêtée par rapport
à par deux motards qui m'ont demandé de
mettre sur le côté et lg flèche qui
m'ont demandé de faire la première fois
et puis il a été un peu plus un peu plus
virulent me demandant de mettre plus sur
le bas-côté gg j'avoue m'être encore
plus sur le bas-côté noblement il ya
plus de vingt côté
tu veux plus aller sur mon côté j'ai
baissé ma vitre je regarde plus le plus
beau côté comment on fait et hélas il a
été acquis c'est pas marc et moi je moi
j'aurais jamel qui me fait ça je me
marrais même si je t'ai sujet pas
exactement 10 h je me suis mis dix ans
fils de [ __ ]
comment ça je me sens bas-côté
vraiment ici y'a pas eu de mots échangés
moi je fais des supers signe j'ai fait
loin des grands signes pour aller vers
la droite aussi et quand j'ai baissé ma
vitre disant qu'il n'y avait plus moyen
de la droite et il sait il s'est énervé
il avait garé sa voiture et puis là il
m'a sorti de la voiture comme si j'avais
comme si j'avais vu j'avais fait entrer
un avion de ligne sur la troupe de
terreur là il a été très virulent il est
essentiel et puis et puis et puis et
puis c'est partir en cacahuète mais
c'est ça qui vous a fait une clé de bras
jamais un hôtel à une dans le ventre
ouais ils ont été entassées assez
violent à ce moment là moi comme je
t'écoute ma famille forcément ça il ya
eu il ya eu un affrontement même mes
frères mes frères étaient là je fais une
clé de bras je sais c'était assez
délicat quand j'étais c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment violent de quoi comme
truquées jeu
c'était dur moi j'ai subi une injustice
quoi qu'on en dise j'ai perdu mon procès
je fais appel
tout n'a pas été fait dans
je suis sûr qu'on a oublié plein de
choses et je vais vous le démontrer mais
mais je crois en la justice de ce pays
et puis je sais qu'on me rende justice
quoi qu'il arrive parce que je suis une
victime je suis victime dans cette
histoire maintenant je me suis jamais
prononcée parce que mes avocats on
pensait que c'était pas mes avocats
j'aime bien me quoi en penser qu'il
fallait pas se prononcer à ce moment là
parce que parce que c'est sacré et ça
risque et danville d'envenimer les
choses et de porter préjudice préjudice
ouais et cette chose que j'ai suivi
leurs conseils je regrette amèrement
aujourd'hui parce que effectivement
quoi qu'on fasse on est perdant tu vois
jusqu'à ce que je peux ce que je trouve
horrible
dans ce [ __ ] de système sais que
j'arriverai 45 minutes de retard à un
repas et puis j'explique que je viens de
faire contrôler par la police c'est pour
ça que j'ai quarante cinq minutes en
retard donc pas se défaire comme si de
rien n'était pas donc finalement c est
normal mais si après tout on trouve
aussi après tout le monde trouve ça
normal pourquoi pas moi c'est bien
normal du droit mais bien on va passer
un deuxième sujet grave
l'islam oui pourquoi c'est grave que
cela ben c'est grave parce que les gens
confondent arabe et musulman déjà et
tous les arabes ne sont pas musulmans il
y en a qui sont catholiques y en a qui
sont juifs et puis ensuite musulmans on
confond aussi souvent avec islamistes et
on peut être musulman sans être
islamistes et avec ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine à new york on est inquiet
de voir une espèce d'amalgamé comme ça
et de devoirs démarre en france une
espèce de racisme anti arabe alors que
la plupart des arabes et des musulmans
d'arrêt prouve ce qui s'est passé à new
york oui il ya un avion qu'ils rentrent
dans la plus grande tour du monde c'est
irrationnel quoi tu vois quand quand les
rationnels se met à chercher c'est c'est
horrible c'est aberrant n'y a pas de
mots
toutes les formes de terrorisme
je condamne à mort mais je condamne à
mort je veux dire par là que ccc ccc
j'arrive pas à trouver mais moi ça me va
je te rassure mais
je crois que là on a décidé de d'akouda
les exterminer tous les terroristes
mais c'est pas en exterminant les
terroristes qu'on va arrêter le
terrorisme c'est justement en
exterminant les terroristes pour
fabriquer les terrorismes voix sinon
l'algérie y aurait plus de plus plus
d'incidents que belle lurette
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas la solution j'ai pas la
science infuse simplement je crois que
la solution est politique qui voient la
solution est politique c'est quoi c'est
sait comment vivre ensemble qu'on va
partager le pack en partager l'eau
arrêté d'humilier les gens tu vois je
tout ce que je peux dire en tout cas
c'est que ça va être difficile d'être
arabe c'est embêtant ouais c'est tout
quand les gens dansent en palestine
après l'attentât qui a eu donc à new
york ouais je sais comment
je suis pas à la place de ces gens là je
moi je suis contre la mort je suis un
citoyen du monde je trouve ça la mort
c'est pourri de mourir à moi je préfère
à la place de mourir d'aller aux bains
douches et de taper d'adriana karembeu
franchement non mais c'est vrai tu vois
je sais c'est vraiment assez vous cendre
est truqué qui est 6ème et elles sont
confrontées à l'avoir matin midi et soir
je me posais la question vous posez la
question parce que je suis arabe
musulman alors alors alors si si si
je n'ai pas la place de ces gens là qui
subissent quiconque une pression
incroyable qui crient tous les soirs en
rentrant chez eux après que leurs
cousins gain de mourir ou que leur frère
vient de mourir
il s'est donc ils sont là ils se
défendent à coups de cailloux je prenne
des il faut il faut il faut être joué
tous les jours il met ça sur le dos des
états unis d'israël il sera les temps
étant très proche des états unis ils
font aussi eu aussi des amalgames et
c'est 100 fois plus facile je me sens
pas plus facile pour eux de faire des
amalgames que que pour les autres je
veux dire que ils sont dans une
situation tellement incroyable les mecs
que je comprends pas du tout mais je je
je fais pas de moment je sais pas penser
que les américains ont trompé d israël
je pense rien du tout pas l'enjeu
il y a il n'y a pas de juste milieu
c'est dans la violence y a pas de juste
milieu il ya et je pense que je pense
qu'ils que ce qui se passe en algérie ce
qui se passe en palestine ce qui se
passe au rwanda ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe en irak avec
l'embargo c'est pas normal c'est pas
bien c'est moi je suis dans une position
super confortable j'ai vendu 450 milles
cassette je je je je roule dans une
super belle voiture j'ai entièrement ma
mère elle est là elle souffrait que les
bras grands ouverts moi je peux juste
vous trouvez ça horrible et puis et puis
prier pour que tout rentre dans l'ordre
maintenant je fais pas de politique et
puis j'ai pas de solution je ne connais
pas les réponses c'est horrible ce qui
s'est passé d'accord on n'enlève en rien
à ce qui s'est passé horrible ya là on
en parle c'est à chaud j'aurais aimé
avoir cette discussion avec vous dans
six mois j'aurais été beaucoup plus
objectif là là c'est horrible on ya eu
des morts il ya déjà il ya des il ya des
femmes qui faisaient le ménage dans la
twin towers et portoricaine qu'avec son
mystère rentrer chez elles car elles
tombent elles ont rien à voir avec tout
ce qui se passe ni aux palestiniens ni
elles ont subi comme comme plein de gens
et et le truc qui m'a quand même assez
frappé je dois l'avouer c'est que j'ai
vu l'information continue depuis que
c'est arrivé j'ai vu que ça sur toutes
les chaînes en permanence j'ai vu aucune
image depuis un an deux des morts qui a
eu en irak parce qu'il passe qui
manquait d'audace belgique n'a vu aucune
image d d d d d on a vu peu d'image du
génocide au rwanda on nous montre que ce
qu'on a envie de montrer ça c'est
déplorable c'est ce que je dis il ya des
informations qui ont relou maintenant si
on décide de tout nous dire et à nous de
protéger porter jugement là je pourrais
avoir un jugement lucide et
constructives mais là là je peux rien
vous dire que je vais vous dire ouais
c'est horrible
alors
du moment ça va être dur de sortir tes
blagues beau film je sais je sais
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial
[Musique]
j'ai qu'une seule envie quand on me
demande va bouger c'est de bouger ma
fille d'habitude et beau jouet interview
croyance
est ce que vous croyez que les drogues
douces conduisent forcément aux drogues
dures
ou manteau rouge
non pas du tout ouais
je sors plein d'ennemis
est-ce que vous avec alain chabat peut
sauver canal+ bien évidemment sans
problème à la super alain chabat alain
chabat peut sauver n'importe qui ouais
ouais bah tu peux sauver canal il peut
sauver canal comme il peut comme avec
comme il peut trouver une solution
sur la planète terre est ce que vous
croyez au sexe sans amour
bien évidemment que non
ça n'existe pas pour ma part si je n'ai
pas de sentiment je ne peux pas produit
fait
donc vous voyez à l'amour sans sexe
j'ai pas dit a fait ça mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'il ment il peut y avoir
une forme d'amour qui n'est pas palpable
concrètement t'as jamais pécho sans
avoir un petit sentiment moi jamais
d'avis ce serait se foutent de la gueule
de ma partenaire et ça c'est pas
possible il faut qui est quand même un
respect mutuel respect passe par l'amour
est ce que vous croyez jamel debbouze ou
pouvoirs surnaturels
alors vous pouvez venir pendant mon
interview comme vous voulez vous a parlé
et je crois qu'il m'a eu je crois qu'il
ya un petit sentiment pour toi mais cui
cui
par contre sans sentiments je veux bien
si tout est elle aussi en a les autres
est ce que vous croyez aux pouvoirs
surnaturels de goldorak bien sûr tu es
beau matin j'ai des preuves un bac gsm
goldorak il existait actarus avec de mon
quartier je comprenne que chirac va être
élu
il ne peut pas être règne à cause des
bruits des odeurs non je serai relou
qu'il soit réélu aujourd'hui de me
[ __ ] de la gueule dans le président de
la république moi c'est qu'on lui
connaît est-ce que voyais au père noël
bien sûr yard
est ce que vous croyez jamel debbouze à
l'effet des crèmes antirides
je ne me prononcerai pas le sujet est
trop délicat célébrons dédicace à mettre
dans la merde pas mal d'institutions
d'accord du des tests cliniques prouvé
dans les laboratoires tokoa que les
crèmes antirides ça marche excuse moi
mais je connais des gens qui depuis des
années m des crèmes anti rides et
est ce que voudrait que patrick fiori
peut à nouveau rencontrer le grand amour
après sa séparation avec la fin du ciom
demande comment il a fait pour
rencontrer une première fois
tout est possible après est ce que vous
croyez que l'homme a vraiment marché sur
la lune donc c'était une manipulation
des studios d'hollywood
sèche et franchement je me pose encore
la question on en parle souvent avec mes
parents ouais
là c'est vrai c'est bizarre quand on
regarde bien moi je vois pas pourquoi
ils sont jamais retournés mais si cela
était une fois alors s'il vient c'est
dit s'il te dis c'était magnifique
c'était un truc incroyable
il réussit retourne pas donc peut-être
s'était passé à la vitesse est bidon et
peut-être ils ont pas été non
est-ce que vous croyez en vous bien sûr
à mort s'il ya bien une personne en qui
je crois c'est web
est ce que vous croyez en moi et base de
plus en plus et figurez-vous au début
non au début j'ai eu au début un peu
après non
abrégée du nom il va droit au mur et
gitans qui changera pas il pourra rien
faire et puis la fune petit à petit et
figurez vous qu'un peu ça me fait
plaisir ça fait que non mais c'est vrai
en plus de plus je regarde chez l'une
des rares émissions que je regarde la
télévision moi je moi j'ai un hymne
non
c'est mon ami me rends elin de lancer sa
jeu
on est les tiens je viens
moi depuis mardi dernier je ne crois
plus aux super héros ou et et bruce
willis mardi
hong ok messieurs direction de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus